I'm so hungry hey there's the new guy we
are starving I know sorry John's running
late but he'll be here is that a blue
streak in your hair yeah you like it
looks good right uh-oh it's happening
what is happening Oh Robbie we love you
but you always do this
do what oh you morph into the guys that
you date that's not true come on what
has happened like once
okay fine that was old me but this is
new Robin so remember when you dated
Spencer used to barbecue Bret was a weak
moment say nice ride nice ride you know
make this brisket sandwich even better
french fries oh I love a good deep fried
taters
but I was thinking meat patties oh good
the bunny instead of the brick-like
chicken EES sprinkles right you know
exactly I'm talking yeah so what you're
a vegetarian are you fish sometimes it's
not that bad it couldn't worse yeah like
bonyen the artiste oh yeah it's a loss
why is that so weird oh yeah I got it
happy birthday Todd cool so it's like a
bunch of gum
it's a vase oh you know because I'm
sculpting now oh it's not just a vase
it's a piece of her soul I dig it well I
can't wait for my birthday thanks man
it's actually pronounced bunion yeah but
no I am NOT an order somewhere no teeth
okay but he was the worst one no yeah
the worst one was the health fanatic
Kevin yeah you know what this is not
fair what is big a Robin Dave come on so
I'm just trying to help Robin unlock her
true potential it's baby steps wait wait
this is the same Robin who refused to
come to my apartment because I lived on
the fifth floor walk-up you had a weird
roommate
remember that's silly weird guy you
should show everyone the move we were
working on earlier
you know that's just it's late
everybody's tired of that okay focus on
form focus on four core cardio comfort
you got it babe
push rock out rock out this is what
livings feels like do you want your
juice no okay that was on the ground for
30 minutes it was very sorry I'm late
everyone mimosa's on me oh what's the
man do it no it's fine hey so this is
Lucy Benjamin my toe and time it is
great to meet everyone this is awesome
hey your hair you did it yeah you look
so good you look great I can never do
that well you know it's just a Robin
thing to do okay it's french toast too
naughty